Hello everyone.
Thank you for coming here for
ARC 310, Resilience
of AWS Cloud.
Uh, my name's Rob Charlton. I'm a principal
technologist focused on resilience in
the financial services business unit.
And
Uh, hi.
Hi, Rob, thank you. Uh, thank you for coming as
well. Uh, I know it's a little bit early, maybe
it's very late, depending on your time zone.
Uh, but, uh, my name's Stephen,
Steve Martin. I'm a,
uh, I'm a technologist at AWS and I
run a team of, uh, security
and, uh,
compliance specialists, uh, basically
everything outside of the. US for financial services.
And we're delighted to be here today to
talk to you about resiliency.
So we're gonna talk about the resilience of AWS
and many of you in the audience might already know
quite a lot about resilience of AWS, like what a
region is,
but hopefully today, even if you know
all that, you're gonna learn something as well.
So what we would say is,
although you may know it,
this technique that we're going to present today has proved
very effective. If you have to explain
some of that to your stakeholders. So if someone on the board
comes to say, well, how is AWS resilient?
This technique works pretty well we found
in terms of explaining that.
So, but first, quick show of hands, how many people have
had enough of PowerPoint, this reinvent?
And we've been watching PowerPoint continuously. Right, good
news, we are ditching the PowerPoint.
Yes, no PowerPoints.
So we're going to old fashioned organic
gluten-free iPad and Apple
pencil. So
We're gonna talk about resilience of AWS, but I'm gonna
start with a little bit of a digression
on what is resilience and how do we
think about it. Now we found
this very useful in terms of explaining
resilience, it's what I call the resilience equation.
I'm gonna come back to this
because
in talking to lots of customers and talking to
financial regulators and other people around the world,
I came to realize that often
there's another resilience equation in mind
when we're having resilience conversations, cos they're
always saying.
What about data centers burning down and undersea
cables being cut,
which absolutely these are things that can happen
and you need to be able to take account of that, but
there's a lot more to resilience besides that.
So I call this the classic resilience equation,
and it got me thinking, well why,
why is that? Why is there this focus on
a more traditional view of resilience?
And here's my view. See if you agree with this, but
I think this comes down to the fact that the way
things fail have changed, and this is nothing
to do with cloud whatsoever.
This is a change in how we build
applications that's been happening over the last 1520
years. So if you think about a,
a traditional application that you might build
for resilience,
usually the way you'd build that er in the past
is in a monolithic style, so
you have one.
Giant application.
Running as a monolith on some piece of
hardware and then for resilience you might have
another copy of it running tens of kilometers
away in another data center.
And the resilience model of this is
Is very simple because if one of them fails,
then the other one takes over.
But the way that we're building things now has changed.
Nowadays teams are usually using
Kubernetes or containers, technologies
and building things in a microservices
style, so instead of that monolith you've got this
network of lots of little services
all connected together and then all built on top of cloud
services.
But this has some important implications.
So let's think about what happens to an application when
it goes wrong in both cases.
So first off, let's look at the monolithic app
and imagine we're plotting a graph here of
traffic reaching this application, this could be any
kind of business application, and here over 24
hours you can see there's a big peak in traffic
in the middle of the day.
Now imagine something's gone wrong.
So, uh, sometime here maybe a
certificate's expired,
and because it's monolithic,
an application has gone down
completely and there's a two hour period where it's just
off, no traffic being received.
And then the engineers come in, they fix it.
Now this is a very,
very easy model to understand and reason
about, and the availability is quite
simple to calculate. You can see we've got 19 of availability
over the day there.
But what happens in the,
the new model?
So now we've got our microservices app.
Same, running the same business
application, same traffic occurring during the day, and
what happens when something fails here?
Now you can see
this model is slightly different because
around about here,
something starts going wrong.
But because it's not one big thing, because
it's a network of microservices, maybe one
microservice is
failing or maybe there's just extra latency
between a couple of services.
The application is not 100% down, so
a proportion of requests that are
reaching that application
start to fail.
And then you can see a bit later, after
a couple of hours, the team implies a fix,
traffic starts increasing again,
and then around here we're back up to full recovery
again. But already you can see
something's a bit different with this graph now because
you could say, well, at no point during that 24
hours was the app 100% down.
So how do you even reason about
up or down, and then.
What about availability? How do you calculate the availability
now? So one way you could do that is you could say,
Let's take the area here.
And divide that by
the area of the rest of the graph, and then you get a
calculation of success rate
for that application.
That relies on knowing what this dotted line
is here,
so you need to know what is the expected traffic hitting your
application. But you can see,
taking a step back,
this is a lot more complicated to reason
about, it's not so straightforward.
Then think about the team supporting this.
They're gonna have to have
better observability skills, better
tooling to be able to work out what is going on to
understand that it's this particular microservice that's
having a problem.
And then recovery might not be as simple as going into
the data center and rebooting one of the,
one of the servers or a rack.
So
my theory is failure has changed and that
impacts
the way things fail, and that means
there's more boxes in my resilience equation.
So let's run through this.
What I'd say is
So although I spent all that time saying that
global infrastructure is not the main focus,
when it comes to the resilience of an application, I'm saying
it's a sum of all of these things,
and along the bottom row
is all the bits that AWS does. And
it starts with a global infrastructure, so, and
that's what we're gonna talk about today is
data centers,
cables, networking,
racks, power, storage.
Where, where does all that go and how do we think about that
when we're building it.
But Application
engineers building cloud
services, building digital services running
on cloud and not using that infrastructure
directly, they're not going into our data centers and
putting things in there.
They're using AWS services.
But then what is an AWS service? An
AWS service
is a distributed software
application that gives access to that infrastructure.
So the engineers are building on services, therefore,
the way that we build and design those services,
the the way that our teams think about resilience
is also a key part of the resilience story.
This also helps you ask better questions
about AWS resilience, because really
you can ask questions about the infrastructure, but
better to ask questions about well what's the resilience of the
services that are running on that infrastructure.
But then lastly,
those services are run by dedicated
teams of people, single threaded teams, and we'll
talk a little bit about those teams as well
today. But the way that those teams
operate the service, the kind of practices and
mechanisms that they have,
the way that they work is also
a key part of the resilience story.
So that's the whole bottom row, that's all
the stuff that AWS does on your behalf,
and you don't need to do anything to enable
that. That all just happens by default, but
it's very important that you're able to
understand and articulate that, particularly
if someone on the board has come to you to say,
well, how does this resilience work,
then being able to explain all of those
boxes is a part of your resilience
story. But
it's not all down to us.
So the top row is all the bit that's
your responsibility.
And it starts with your architecture.
So which AOS services have you picked?
How are you composing them together, what choices
have you made?
Maybe you're working with an AOS solutions architect
who's helping guide you with that.
You might be using the AOS well architected framework,
uh, so condensed knowledge of 19
years of running AWS and working with customers,
compressed into a number of different pillars,
one of which is the reliability pillar giving you
guidance on how to build for resilience.
But as you just saw,
because the way applications are built
is changing,
the way that you design your software is also
important. So it's important that
the software engineers in your teams are also part
of this resilience conversation. They can't just
leave it to the infrastructure team
or the architects anymore.
So we have some more guidance available.
There's a resource called the Amazon Builders
Library, where we've put a lot of our secret
sauce in how to build distributed
software applications over the last 20
years that we've been building AWS
and that's all available for you to use as well.
Then lastly, and I think most importantly.
Once you've deployed your applications into
AWS,
you have to keep them running and keep them resilient,
and that's where your operations
teams
come into, come into play.
So what
processes and practices
do they operate? How are they deploying the software,
how are they monitoring it?
What incident response procedures have they got?
When there is an incident and afterwards
when they're doing the root cause analysis,
how do they perform that and how do they extract
the maximum amount of learning possible
and then build that in as part of your resilience
life cycle.
So what I would say is all of
this
goes towards making you resilient while you're running
on AWS.
It's a shared responsibility model. The
top row is down to you and your engineers and
we'll go into that as we go through
the er the talk today. The bottom bit
comes from AWS.
So,
before we get into the global infrastructure,
Let's talk a little bit about
the risks that AWS thinks about. Thank you very much, Mr.
Rob. Really
useful
to start thinking about risks and how
AWS helps you address these risks.
What we find is
in a lot of, a lot of the conversations
that we're having with our customers, they're struggling
with explaining
uh how AWS is actually managing
these risks.
And then there's a lot of overfocus on
areas that perhaps you don't need to focus on,
which takes your resources away from what you
should be doing, which is that top part of the equation.
And so what we want to do is we want to help you
today to understand how to articulate
to people that
you're perhaps working with or you know,
talk to your leadership,
um, some of you might be leaders here.
How to really frame this so that
you are really comfortable of explaining
why you're gonna focus on that top piece of the equation
rather than focusing on
the infrastructure. You know, we see a lot of customers, we, we
came from financial services.
Background, uh,
and so therefore
there's a sort of a governmental or regulatory kind
of focus on these questions as well,
um, so this is where this came from and I
think thinking about it from a risk point of view is very helpful.
And so when we, uh, when we think
about let's say if we go back to this like where do we
put our data centers when we build our
region,
uh, we really sit there and we think about,
uh, the kind of environmental risks
that may come up.
And I, I think uh there's a lot of people here from all parts
of the world, so, you know, uh, sadly
not everywhere is
immune to these things, right? And you know if you
take India for example, you know, it has a seismic
plane and you know you have to think about these things,
and we actually invest in two different regions to handle
that. So you know, you think about earthquakes, you
can't always avoid those situations,
but we build our data centers and we build our
environments to handle
uh the kind of pressures that might bring.
Uh, you know, Japan for example as well.
Uh, we think about flooding.
You know, we think about flood plains. These are, these are important
things, you know, you go buy a house, you think about, well, is
there a river nearby?
We think about these things too.
Uh, we think about
other environmental factors that we can't predict these
days, you know, the world's changing.
So you have, you know, you've seen what happened in
Indonesia recently, which is a bit sad,
where you have, uh, you know, like a,
a year's flooding in, in almost a week.
So we think about those things as well.
And then we think about
uh
other things, right?
Uh we think about uh the
physical
threats that you're that you're under. Now,
a lot of us.
Especially someone my age,
I come from an environment where
we actually used to build the data centers and run them
ourselves and put the racks in and think
about these uh more physical areas.
And for some, you know, more and more, you know, people
who are born in the cloud or companies that are born in the cloud
may not think about these things, but we do.
So we insulate you from as
much as possible from
servers crashing,
you know, fiber getting cut,
fire suppression,
cooling failures, power failures.
And you know we do that through
thinking about redundancy in
the way that we build our data centers and
also providing additional redundancy
when we come, we get to explain this when we think
about how we put our ASEs together and
how we build our regions
and then you know we think about one of the things that I'm really
passionate about AWS
is security
uh because I'm responsible for quite a bit with my customers
and
we really focus on uh.
Uh, security in our
organization, we put security first. Um,
a lot of organizations struggle with that.
So you think about that top line, you know, bringing
that shifting security left.
Well, that's something that we've really,
uh, brought into our organization. We
do security and resiliency. We've shifted as
far left as possible in the organization
and so that,
uh, we think about malware,
insider threat, DDoS, you know, we have our
DDoS, uh, prevention.
Um, so you know,
that's
really important to us. So again,
we have a lot of material that's out there that
explains how we've done these things, and if you
go and look at it,
uh, if you look at our security services, you'll see
how it explains our DDoS services, it explains
how we think about
culture of security, how we've pushed it left,
um, and then we think about software.
Of course you know when we design our software.
And we think about how we build our software,
we're thinking all the time about
uh not just the functionality that our customers ask
us for,
but we actually think
before we do anything, we have to make sure that we
have really thought about the kind of
threats and issues that might happen within our software.
The, the kind of uh
issues that you have with change, we're quite innovative in
how we do change, you know, we do
uh the rate of change in this organization. I
and when I tell customers how many changes we do, it's
quite frightening and I think they look at me and go white.
I think uh I don't think we could do that,
but we've worked to be better at change
and to deploy change of pace.
And uh you know,
I think uh Rob talked about traffic,
but we look at traffic patterns and we design
our systems to handle surges in traffic,
uh to think about how we can manage any sort of additional
capacity. So all of those things are put into it and Rob's
gonna explain
later how some of that works.
Yeah, so as we go through this, we'll pop back to this
slide and we'll cross out the risks as
we demonstrate how we've mitigated those. But
Steve, let's, uh,
let's talk about global infrastructure first. Yeah, I
think, I think a really important concept, and I, it's
interesting. I don't know if how many of you here have ever
been in a presentation from AWS
from uh maybe a
a solution architect or someone like that, and they've got
a, a little picture of data
centers
into a little region and they skip through it, off
they go through it.
And they get, and then suddenly you're into all the
fun stuff and services and what we do.
It's really interesting
when you sit down and you think, what is actually
in a region?
How do we build it?
And, and a lot of your uh colleagues
that may not be
as directly involved with AWS as you
maybe don't know.
You may know, that's great, and I hope you
do know.
Uh and if you don't, you'll find this really useful way of explaining
it to them. Um, but what we
kind of started with was,
what do people actually know when, when they
come to AWS and they want to use it. And remember
the kind of companies that we're dealing with are kind
of hybrid in nature.
They'll have SAS vendors, they'll have
some level of cloud exposure, and they'll have a lot
of legacy. So it's kind of a mix of things with the companies
that we're dealing with.
So what we kind of find was, no matter where you
went in the organization, right up to the,
the people that ran it, the board, the people that invested,
they all knew they had some data centers.
Because they paid for them,
right? And they generally knew where they were.
And they generally knew that er
they had one data center
that they ran workloads and then they had another data
center for backups.
This is kind of the model they had in their heads, and
some sort of synchronous or asynchronous replication
maybe. And so what we, uh,
and then they have a kind of standard kind of thinking that
there's maybe a database or an
application sitting in one of those data centers. So we sort of
started with this and said well what would it take to build a
region? So the first
thing we kind of thought was,
you might need some more stuff.
You might need a few more data centers.
And so Rob, Rob's very helpfully
here. Uh, drawing
these out for me, right?
So, uh, it's like magic, isn't it? And
they're even square, well, very good, right?
So we thought we need a lot more infrastructure if you're
actually gonna build a region.
So we kind of like, well what do you actually need?
So you know, we, you know,
uh, here we go.
This is one
set of maybe data centers,
and then we have another set over here in DC
2. And then because we like to be massively
redundant,
we have another one down here in DC 3.
Now for those that are guessing what these things could be,
uh we'd kind of call those availability
zones.
Um,
so that's the kind of logical access that you
have as a customer.
You have the,
you don't really get down to choose the data center.
Some of our, some of our availability zones have quite a few
data centers in them.
There's at least one data center.
OK, great. And then we'd like have to,
so we've only got one connection here that's not pretty,
not very useful.
So we'd love to we'd we'd build a lot of
interconnects between these availability zones.
OK.
And there would be high speed
interconnects
that would allow uh
synchronous replication between these availability
zones. And even within the data set, even
within the, where you've got more than one data center, we
would have tremendous amount of
uh interconnects between these data centers, effectively
there's a minimal transit time.
OK. So this is starting to shape up
a bit more like a, like a region.
And then we'd sort of think about power.
We like power. It's very useful.
Uh, so we'd have power, that's,
is that those ziggy zag things?
Power. Alright, OK.
So, and typically what we try and do is we try and draw
the power from
different grids if we can, or at least different distribution
points on the grid. Not everywhere has a separate
provider in the grid.
Different countries
uh tend to have
different approaches to this.
But where we can, we will try and draw those
power from diverse sources and even
within those data centers we'll have other ways
to power those data centers and those availability zones.
We'll have, you know,
uh, because we're managing the risk of
disruption, so we'll have, uh, generators and
oil tanks with gasoline in
them. Uh, you've seen that in Spain recently
where there was a, a country, Spain Spain and
Portugal, I don't know if you were, they had a
outage earlier in the year. It's very unfortunate that, you
know, with their new kind of approach to solar, the,
the grid became unstable.
And uh you know, because
we have these things we're able to run through it.
Uh
and we'll uh also, how far apart, yes,
good question.
We don't really think about distance.
We think about
what's the transit time, what's the return transit time?
And what we find is a good ready reckon
for this about 1 millisecond, I think, Rob.
Single digit milliseconds. Yes, yes.
Single digit milliseconds.
So that kind of leads you to, and
if people are kind of familiar with infrastructure,
that kind of still leaves you with our ability
to do synchronous replication between these
uh availability zones.
So if you go and look at uh
our literature, it'll talk about, you know, tens
of kilometers
kind of thing, depending on which country you're in.
And then that allows you some flexibility about where
you put things in terms of
uh managing the risks that we talked
about earlier about,
you know, environmental risks and managing
the floodplain risks or even seismic risks in
some places.
So if you go back there, you know,
our placement of the,
the data centers and availability zone
takes into account these things and tries
to minimize the impact of these things as much as possible.
They're not, it's not residual, you know, there's always
a residual risk, but it's, it's kind of gone.
OK, so that looks a bit
like a region,
if anyone's looked at this before, right?
And now we're gonna sort of talk about uh
using some of the AWS services like RDS
for example. Yeah, so what is
that application that was running in
the on-premise environment? What does that look like when it's
in AWS? Well,
I think it looks a bit like this, Rob. Tell
me if I'm wrong. I think we have,
we'll put a database into
ESE1,
to do, go onto the console, launch our launch
our database, our, our
relational database service allows us to do that.
And we'll probably replicate it over
to
uh ESE 2.
OK, and we'll have the app replicated
as well. The data's replicated so we'll have multiple
instances of the app.
And I think we'll try and have another instance of it
in
uh E3, might be a reed replica.
Um, so the data's there if we need it.
And that makes that application, if
we think back to the original
uh diagram that we looked at,
where we just had two data centers and a traditional model,
maybe some cluster set that's running across
from data center one to data center two,
we now have something that's a
lot more robust,
right, and it's taking care of other,
if we go back to those risks,
we can kind of knock off a few more, Rob, I think.
Yes, the thing to think about is how does this
resilience work now?
So if I put a uh if I put a load
balancer in the middle of this.
Steve, do you want to walk through, how does that work?
Well, you know, if I'm a customer and I'm a
client going to into want to access
that app, uh, instead of going
directly into, uh, the
initial app
on availability one, which you could do,
uh, if you use our, uh, load balancing
service, you'll go to that, that'll proxy
out the workload, and it might even be that
you go to
uh AZ, you know, you might go to all three AZs,
or you might go to just one of them.
Right, but the load balance will understand the availability
of the other parts of the application.
And in the case that
er for some reason
er the server crashed.
The data center went on fire,
the availability disappeared in a cloud of smoke,
availability zone disappeared in a cloud of smoke. You, your
customers should be able to recover into
SSE2 and SE 3.
There might be
some minor delays, there might be some minor
operational adjustments to do that, but effectively
it should be fairly seamless,
uh, and uh that,
I think that's how it would work, Rob. Yeah,
so that that way of deploying an
application with a copy in
one copy of the application in each availability
zone, which particularly if it's something mission
critical, that's what we'd advise you to do.
Out of the box, that's taken care of the
rest of these.
Uh, Physical risks that we've got on here, so if
a server crashes in one AZ,
you know, you can fail over to
another AZ,
uh, disk crashes,
uh, if there was a fire in one of the availability
zones data centers, then we're also taking
care of that, and cooling failure
and power failure as well.
Uh, you know, funny, I was, er, when I first started
in AWS,
er, having run a lot of stuff.
Uh, and I seen that one of our AZs had a fire,
one of our data centers had a fire at a at a mass panic.
I was like, oh my God, we've had a fire.
But the customers weren't bothered by it. They're insulated
from that. You know, we run our data centers very
hot, uh, and they're designed to do that.
So, um,
yes, but that they're starting to look at, that's quite an
interesting design there, Rob, in terms of resiliency.
So I wanna talk a little bit now about
the AWS services, because you remember we said
that AWS service design is also an
important part of the resilience story.
So everything that I've drawn here.
The thing that says app and RDS, so
app is running on the EC2 service,
so this is what we would call an EC2
instance. Elastic Compute
cloud instance.
But these are what we would call resources, these are the
deployed bits of a service that
you, the customer is looking after.
But it's a good question to ask, well, what is the service?
And really
what we're talking about is there's an EC2
API.
That you're calling and that's what's deploying
the the virtual machines and running them for you.
So there's another EC2 API
over here.
And another EC2 API over
here. So lo and behold, the EC2
service is itself
a multi AZ application.
So the services that you're building on are
relying on the same resilience
benefits of that multi AZ model.
So all the risks that we show
also apply, the mitigations also apply
to the AWS services.
Now, there's a very, very important
distinction here which comes back to the shared responsibility
model, because if you notice, this
EC2 service.
Steve here when he was building this application,
decided to put EC2 instances
in each availability zone.
Now if you wanted to, let's say you were running
some uh huge payment
processing system which is processing
credit card payments for a third of the United
States. You could put that
onto one
giant EC2 instance in one
AZ if you wanted to. That's, that's
down to you. We would absolutely say please don't
do that. You could do that.
Please don't doubt.
Uh, deploy it onto several 100
EC2 instances across multiple AZs,
but that is on your side of the shared responsibility
model. There are other kinds of services
though. Now, many of you may have seen.
In architecture diagrams,
usually in the corner of the diagram there'll be a
picture of a bucket
with the S3 service icon on there, and
that might make you think, hang on, what is that? Is that
a single point of failure?
What's it doing down there?
Is it, is it in those, is it there somewhere?
It's not uh outside of the region or
floating in space there, so the S3
service is also, let me choose a better
color for that.
Is also
implemented as APIs that you're calling.
When you're calling put and get, there's an S3
API here, here and down
here. So by
Amazing coincidence, it's
also a multi AZ application.
There's a difference here,
because this application is one that AWS
is managing on your behalf. You're not choosing,
well, unless you use
S31 zone, you're not choosing
the the availability zone where your
data is being stored. You just give S3 your
cat picture
and it breaks it up into lots and lots of little pieces and
then stores it very redundantly across
the region on your behalf.
So it's very important,
going back to your application,
that your engineers are aware of the kinds of
services that they're using.
Are they zonal services
like EC2
or are they regional services like S3,
because the resilience model changes
depending on how they're working with that.
So What we also
want to cover, so we've covered the global infrastructure,
we've spoken about that.
And we've spoken about
um AWS service design,
how the service is designed and how they er
implement resilience.
We also spend some time talking about
AWS service operations.
So the teams, the single threaded teams
behind the services, how do they, how do
they work and how do they
include resilience in their processes.
This goes back to the risks that we talked about before.
Absolutely, so one of the key risks that we haven't
covered yet,
er, we haven't covered bugs and we haven't covered change
and deployment risk.
So let's go back to that.
So what I want to do is imagine that
there's a new AWS service team.
And they're building a new service, as let's run
through the kind of life cycle they run through and the
process they would go through to build and deploy
that service and get it out into production.
Now these teams
are run by single threaded teams
that we call two pizza teams. Many of you may
have heard that terminology, but this is not a kind of
sad and lonely UK one
person pizza. This is a massive, big and
friendly American pizza, so we're talking
about 12 to 14 people
here. Might be Americans here, we have to be careful what we
say. They're lovely pizzas.
So, um,
these single threaded teams, they run
everything to do with that service. So they build
the software,
they deploy the software, they carry the
pages, so when something goes wrong they do the product
management of the software as well.
They are all encompassing, so a service
like S3
will be composed of hundreds of thousands
of different service teams, there will be all of those
teams, single thread running a component
of that service.
So with our new service being deployed,
it all starts with something called the
operational readiness Review.
So the operational readiness review
is a gate that
the team has to go through
where we would check a number of axioms.
So one of those axioms would be
ensure that you have enough capacity in your service
across all three availability zones so that
the service will carry on running unimpeded
if one availability zone is impaired.
So they need to have +50%
at least capacity in all three availability
zones to be able to do that.
There's a number of these axiom checks
in the operational readiness review and you'll see
er as I go through this,
how that builds up over time.
But this is a key part of how do we maintain
a high bar when new services come
online because we're making sure that everything in that
operational readiness review
is all the things that we've learned over the years and
how to make sure that service is built in the
right way. And
er nowadays this is something that we go
through every year, so it's an annual
recheck to make sure that we're still maintaining
that high bar.
But eventually the team will be ready
and they'll start building the software, so
a lot of requirements will go onto the backlog, the team
will be writing the code.
But eventually we have to get to the point of deploying
that software out now.
When we last published it, I think it was 2014,
we were making 50 million deployments
a year, and that's quite a long time ago now,
so you can only imagine how many changes
we're making,
uh, per second as we're
deploying this software out
into the field. So if you think about it,
38 Edibus regions
around the globe, 120 availability zones,
200+ services.
And making 50 million deployments a year
over 10 years ago,
how can we keep that safe,
as we're making all of that change and your own mission
critical applications are running on top of that.
So the way that we do that is we do it very carefully
and we use pipelines, we use automation
extensively in that process.
So it all starts with a pre-production
stage. Now that contains everything
that you might expect in a er
pre-production deployment of
code review with peers,
um,
performance testing, configuration
testing in lots of early stage environments,
environments which mirror the production environment and
all its dependencies as well.
But eventually,
once he got through those pre-production checks, and this is
all done automatically as well.
So another thing to bear in mind is these changes
that we're talking about, 50 million changes a year,
these are not
massive new feature changes, these are
typically very, very small changes, just a
few lines of code
where the developers made that small change, committed
it to Git,
and at that point, the automated
tools take care of everything from that point onwards.
So now we start the production deployment pipeline,
and it starts with a stage that we call one
box.
So it's very, very small change will be deployed
to typically 1 EC2
instance in one availability zone,
in one region around the world and then we
wait. We wait for a period
called the bake time,
and the reason we do that is we're trying to wait
for any
latent bugs or hidden bugs to
emerge during that period, so we'll, we'll be
testing it at that point. It'll be receiving
live customer traffic, this one instance.
If there's not enough customer traffic, we'll send it synthetic
traffic as well.
If there's any problem detected,
so if any of the monitoring is off,
then that change will be rolled back.
We're very er careful to ensure rollback
safety, so the change will be rolled back automatically
by the tooling and it will be sent back to the developer.
But
assuming we get through that, uh, and it
passes,
then the change is rolled out to one
whole availability zone, so all the EC2
instances in one AZ for that service
will get this new copy of the software.
And then we wait again, we wait again for the
bake time
to check to see if anything shows up.
As a part of the deployment, what we usually
do is we ramp the traffic up,
starting at zero to this new deployment
to 50%, 100%, and then
on to 150%.
The reason we do that is to make sure
that the software itself has been built
so it can take
one extra availability zone's worth of
traffic when it gets deployed, so it always
goes up to 150%.
Assuming we go through that, then the
change will be, the small change will be deployed out
to one whole region.
So one region somewhere in the world, all the EC2
instances in 3 availability zones
in that region.
And then we wait again for the baked time. There's
a lot of waiting involved here.
If any problem is detected, it'll
be rolled back.
But assuming it's fine, then the whole process starts
again, but usually we would double up at that point, so
we would go through one box in two regions.
And then one availability zone in two regions
and then doubling up again and eventually
that change will have made its way out
to all
38 regions around the world.
But if the, just imagine there's a problem.
We get to region 37 out of 38, this
change has been absolutely fine,
and some customer request comes in and it
exposes a bug and it's picked up by the
monitoring.
Purely automatically,
that change will be unpicked and rolled back
from all the EC2 instances in 37
regions, it will put back to the last known
good version,
and completely unpicked from
everywhere around the globe and then sent back to the
developer. And then the whole thing
has to start again. They have to go through, make
a change, go through the code review and start it
again. So you can see we're being
extremely careful about this process because
we know how important it is to get this right.
My wallpapering, excellent.
Um. So
At that point, the change is now deployed
out, and that's all been done by
automated tooling.
So at this point.
We're now running in production and that same two
pizza team are responsible for looking
after that.
Now there's a very useful reinforcing factor
here in that if I've deployed a change.
I made a change myself
and I've deployed it and it's gone out to the field,
and now I'm carrying the pager.
Then if that goes wrong and I get paged
at 4 a.m. on Sunday to say your
change has gone wrong,
that's a very useful reinforcing factor to make
sure that I'm very careful in future about making
that change.
But now the changes aren't in production and we're monitoring
it, and I'll come back to monitoring in a second, but
we have a huge number of
metrics. You can say that we're metrics obsessed.
So if you look in some of our internal pages
where we have the dashboard for S3,
say, you will see pages
and pages and pages of
metrics covering every aspect of that
service.
Starting with some above the line metrics on
uh service health, so telling us
is this service healthy, is it all up and running
as expected.
And then lots of diagnostic metrics below
that going down to the P99.9
latency in the Sydney region for some
small aspect of the service. I'll come back to why
there's so many in a, in a minute.
So those uh metrics have all
got several alert thresholds on there.
If those alert thresholds are crossed
and the right conditions are met, then someone
in the team is gonna get paged and then they have to go and
address that issue.
There's two more important aspects I wanted to cover
here, so
although we do try very hard
to try and eliminate as many problems as possible
and you've seen how careful we are,
bugs will occur and sometimes they will get
through this process.
So
When we have an incident,
then we run through a
process called correction of error. Now it'd be very
unusual if any of you
in the enterprises where you work, don't have
a root cause analysis process, it's very
common, but we're very, very particular
about the root cause analysis process which we run
through called correction of error. Now this runs all the way
through Amazon. If you go to the correction
of error tool,
you'll find that there's
not only things to do with AWS but also
roof blown off fulfillment center in Florida
during a storm and.
I put decaffeinated coffee into the caffeinated
coffee pot, which is quite a serious incident,
er, so everything like that has a
correction of error inside Amazon.
Now the reason we're very particular is there's a very
set structure
to this, so we ask very, very particular
questions, so it starts with,
How did you detect the problem?
So was it detected by a customer?
Now that's very rare nowadays, and
if it was detected by a customer, then immediately
the answer to that is, well we need some monitoring in
place for that particular aspect that's just
been shown up.
So you can start to see more monitoring and alerting
comes into play.
But more typically it'll be one of our,
one of our alerts picked it up and
we found out in 30 minutes that something was going
wrong. But then it asks, as a thought experiment,
how could you cut that time
to detect by half?
And that probably means lowering an alert threshold
or.
Adding again some new monitoring lines, so you
start to see
how we get towards having
so many metrics on those monitoring charts.
And then we ask, well,
how did you resolve
the issue? What did you do, what kind of run book
did you use to do it?
And then also as a thought experiment,
how could you reduce the blast radius
of that problem by 50%, and that might mean
reducing the number of customers impacted,
reducing the time it took to
recover from that, so.
We'd then beer building actions
out of the back of that correction of error process which would
go on to the team's backlog for them
to do.
This process is tracked by our senior
principal engineers, some of the most tenured engineers
in AWS to make sure that these actions are
followed up on.
And the team then goes on to build it.
But we also have a section where we want to get to the absolute
root cause,
and this section is called the five whys.
If any of you have kids, if you've got a 4 year old
and you'd be very familiar with them, just asking well
why.
So this process works to try and get to
an absolute actionable root cause,
so we might say,
Why did the service fall over, because
Rob ran a script with the wrong parameter. Well
why did Rob run a script with the wrong parameter?
Was it an issue where he hadn't gone through the
training or well why wasn't it automated?
Uh, so why was the wrong parameter accepted?
Well, we, we had a backlog task to do that
but we prioritized something else. So we'll just
keep going, keep asking why
until we get to some actionable, blame
free. Actions off the back
of that, so we don't think it's acceptable that
the root cause of this problem was Rob. We
want to get to something deeper that we can fix.
Now,
er, from time to time we will also run
through correction of errors and
look for any patterns
within that. So we have a group called the deployment safety
working group who will run through and look to see if there
are any trends or patterns in there where we're encountering
the same problem
multiple times.
And then what they will do is
say, OK, well, what can we, what can we
learn from that? And there's usually one of two things.
So either
Some new best practices,
so this is how things feed into the axioms
in the operational readiness reviews, so we've learned
something from that.
Or
there's gonna be
some new automations in our
pipelines,
so they might add some stages to the pipeline.
Uh, where we're going to build in some new automated
checks to try and prevent that kind of thing in
the future. Then
the last part of this
is a um
what I would say is really the beating heart
of AWS. This is the the
machine that makes the whole thing go round
and this is a call called the weekly
optometrics call.
Um
So this is
a
critical inspection and
learning and teaching event
that happens every week inside AWS.
So what we do is we get um
the leaders and the team from all
200 service teams to join this call.
The AWS senior technical leadership will join
and run the call as well, those senior principal
engineers, the most tenured engineers will
be on there.
And we run through a number of stages in there, and
it starts with, starts with quick wins.
So, uh, any quick wins from the
previous week, so the reason we do that is, so
let's say the S3 team have found some new technique
to reclaim, uh,
unused storage and they freed up, uh,
several petabytes of storage.
So it's good that we kind
of celebrate those wins, but also the
other teams on the call will say, ah, I
can use that and I'll put that into my service as well,
so it's a great way of sharing that knowledge amongst
the team.
We run through
any um
very informative correction of errors
from the previous week as well, so if there's been a
er service incident, we'll run through that
and those er tenured engineers
will go through and say well what can we learn from
that? What's the maximum amount of knowledge
we can get from that.
Those events
And then we have a section called spin the wheel.
Now when this was done face to face, there used to be a physical
wheel that they would spin,
and this wheel has the
all 200 services written
on there.
If you spin the wheel, and we do it twice, and
then we'll pick 2 service
teams, if you're chosen,
you have to step up to the mic and then you have to
present your metrics from the
previous week.
Now. You'd be
uh subjected to a forensic
examination by the most senior
engineers in AWS as to
what happens with your metrics. So you can imagine
that you're going through your pages of metrics.
And let's say we're looking at the
P99 latency in
the Sydney region.
It went upside down cos it's Sydney,
er, and so we have a graph.
And let's say it looks a bit like this.
Then they'll say, well, what is that spike?
What does that mean? Have you investigated that?
And this is where it becomes a teaching event as well, because
they'll say things like, ah well we've seen a pattern
like this when we were
uh in the early days of Dynamo
DB and we learned these things. So
maybe you wanna consider doing this in your service
or checking this or introducing some new
processes and practices.
Um, or maybe they'll be looking at your alert
thresholds.
So a common one is,
let's say you've got a service
and.
Let's get this big rid of this big bump.
Let's say it looks like this, and then the alert threshold
is up here.
So what's that telling you? Well,
It's looking like the alert threshold is too high,
so maybe you've just set that alert threshold at the
wrong level because if there's a problem with that
service, then it's not going to cross the threshold.
It could be a couple of things, maybe you've just said it
in the wrong way, you haven't been following our best practices,
or it could be
that in the previous week or earlier you've made
some performance improvements. You've brought down
whatever that thing is measuring, but you haven't
yet changed the alert threshold.
So they'll say, well, come on, you need to bring that down and make that a bit
tighter.
So it's this kind of learning which takes place.
During that exercise,
er, and it was a great way of allowing the
junior teams to learn from those senior
tenured engineers and
build that learning into their operations. So
there will be a number of actions which come out of this,
so a lot of actions out of the ops metrics,
actions out of the correction of error process,
and those will go onto that team
backlog.
And then they'll build it into the service and that's
how the cycle continues.
Now also worth noting at this point that
the things on that backlog, the features
on that backlog
are all put there, well about 80
to 90% of it comes from you.
So you might find that your uh account
teams that are working with you might
bring um some service teams
to you to talk from time to time.
The reason they're doing that is they're trying to
find out what is it that you need, what changes
that you need.
So if you're able to harness that
and work with those, then that's a great way
to get the features that you need into AWS
because that goes directly onto that backlog and
then those features go into AWS
and then get deployed.
So What have we learned now? If
we go back to our board of risks.
So
Now we, we can't, I wouldn't say that we
just eliminate bugs completely, but we think we've
got pretty good at eliminating bugs through all the
pre-production checks and the way that we
do things.
And we've also covered change in deployment
risks.
I've got a little bit of time, so it might also
cover. Surges in
traffic.
Now, to do with surges in traffic,
let's imagine.
Who? Let's
imagine that you've opened a pizza
restaurant. And this
pizza restaurant
has got a great feature that you can go to the restaurant
and ask for a pizza and you get a pizza in
one minute.
So you've just launched this restaurant, it's doing OK,
and then you find that Taylor Swift has tweeted
about this restaurant
and the news has gone out and suddenly there's a massive
queue of people coming up to your
restaurant. So there's a few interesting aspects about
the way that this works, which means
dealing with a surge in traffic like that can be quite
tricky.
So let's
say this is the
Number of customers
coming in. And
then Time
to pizza.
So right at the start,
We're getting there, then.
We're doing OK, time for pizza is pretty low,
but what tends to happen is, this is gonna go up
and up and up and up,
and then any system, whether it's a pizza pizza
restaurant or a,
Digital service that you're running,
after a while,
things start to take
too long, so in the pizza restaurant,
the oven's gonna be full of pizza, there's gonna be mozzarella
on the floor, the chef is having a, uh, having
a bad day.
In the digital service, the database is gonna be
getting slower and slower, the disks are gonna
be much more contention, the network's getting
contention, eventually the service starts to slow,
slow down.
But there's 2
important things to think about here. The first is your,
your SLA with your customers. Remember you're getting a pizza
in a minute, so there's some kind of SLA.
Where at this point.
They just start giving up.
So you kind of breach the SLA and then the customer
gives up.
Now,
interesting aspect here with digital services
is, I mean this would be unusual in a pizza
restaurant, but what happens is you put your request in
for a pizza.
And it's taken longer than
acceptable, maybe you've given up after 2 minutes.
So that's what we call a timeout.
So at that point you're gonna go away,
hungry,
without your pizza.
But the team is still making your pizza, it's
still going into the oven, so there's no way for you to
tell them, actually I don't want that anymore,
because the the system is busy.
So that's kind of compounding the problem
because you've gone and asked for a pizza and then it's still
being made and now you've gone away again.
That's a bit of a problem, but
If you've dealt with digital services, you'll
know what will happen at that point.
What happens is you do a
retry.
So, rather than just going away and
going to get McDonald's or something like that, you're gonna
come back and put in another order for a pizza.
So now as this traffic is going up, we're compounding
the problem.
Because we had our.
Timeout value here,
and we start retrying, so you're gonna ask for another pizza,
so you've now got two pizza orders in there,
so you can just see this gets worse and worse and
worse, and you enter a stage which
we call overload, you get into congestive
collapse,
where rather than,
Getting a pizza every minute, it gets slower and slower and slower,
and now we're not able to make any pizzas whatsoever.
So this is the situation which we wanna try
and avoid.
Now, what we would say is
before opening your pizza restaurant, you would
want to do an awful lot of performance testing
to make sure, to try and identify what is the
maximum number of pizzas that we can make and what
happens when
Taylor Swift tweets
and then we get a,
a backlog of work which we just cannot cope
with whatsoever.
So
how do we think about that? So what we could do is we could turn
this around and do another graph
now. Where
Going to introduce a couple of terms, so
Throughput
Is the number of customers coming in and
asking for a pizza,
and goodput.
Is the number of customers who actually walk away
successfully with a pizza in a reasonable amount of
time. Now we can
draw the overload situation again in a
new way by saying what happens here, so
as we start off.
Throughput is the same as goodput.
Because
we're not too busy at this point, people are getting their pizzas,
it's fine,
but as we enter that state of congestive
collapse, this starts to tail off and we're
plateauing here.
Plateauing,
er, and
eventually we reach our overload condition
where it just gets so busy we're no longer
able to make any pizzas and that's a bit of a disaster.
What we wanna do
is we would like to extend this
a bit further.
As much as possible.
So what I'm going to talk about here is
one technique that we use inside ADOS. This
is not the only technique, it's a technique that
you can use as well.
There's articles on this in the Amazon
builders' library that you can take away,
and this technique is called load shedding.
So a very, very simple idea. What we want to do
is. In this period
here, we were successfully
serving customers and making pizzas.
We want to protect that as much as possible.
What we want to avoid is this dropping back to zero.
The way we can do that is to say here.
We're gonna start throwing work away,
so we know the number of pizzas because we did
our performance testing, we know the number of pizzas
that we can make.
So beyond that point, we're just going to tell customers,
no, sorry, we're full, go away.
But we're gonna keep
protect the fact that we can make some pizzas and the
effect that this has is
we can extend this line so we're still
able to
serve a fixed number of customers.
And carry on and that buys us vital
time, because what we can do now is we've got time,
we know we're in an overload situation,
we can bring on some more capacity, we can kind of wheel
in some more pizza ovens,
hire some chefs,
get some more mozzarella and tomato ordered,
and we buy ourselves extra time. Now unfortunately,
it's not a
permanent solution, apart from the fact we're turning work
away.
Eventually,
when so much traffic arrives, the cost
of shedding that load, the cost of
telling people you've got to go away also overwhelms
the service.
So what you'd usually find is at some
point this is also gonna drop to zero.
So it's not a permanent solution, but what this means is
if you're in that situation of overload,
you've now got a mechanism to protect yourself
and buy valuable extra time
to be able to recover from that.
Now obviously the right answer here is that in
advance you'd have tested to
beyond the Taylor Swift tweeting point
and you'd be able to recover your pizza restaurant
without doing this,
but this is a vital technique to make
sure that you're protecting the work that you're able
to do. So
We covered one more bonus
risk.
Let me talk about security risks a little bit. Yeah, go
on. So, um.
I learned something that was really good.
Thank you, pizzas.
Pizzas. I learned about, I didn't know you were a Taylor Swift
fan. OK, so.
We talked about
Um,
we talked about the deployment,
the pipelines and how we deploy,
how we can deploy at scale. We talked very carefully.
But what if we don't want to do that?
What if we wanna do something else and speed it up?
Right, what if we've got a situation that we need to deal
with? So I'm sure all of you
had, uh, I guess a lot of you had fun
for a log for Jay.
Yeah. Yeah,
exactly right.
Uh, I've talked to a lot of my customers, you
know, in this space,
and I think what they really find quite interesting is,
uh, how do you deal with that? How
do you deal with,
you know, situations like that. So actually what
we can do is we can go back to those pipelines
because they're well formed, well structured,
and we have clear mechanisms to,
uh, we use the word mechanisms in AWS, we
don't use the word process, right? Uh,
but we have clear approaches about how we're going to deploy
safely. So in the case
where
you need to respond to a situation
fast,
we can speed it up.
OK, it's a balance.
Right, you know, all the teams are on it.
So, uh, in the case of there's a really good,
uh,
there's a really good YouTube video where,
uh, we go through this, um,
but, and you can look it up, you'll see it.
Um,
but basically where customers have taken,
you know, people that have,
who are very careful in themselves but
have all the sort of, because they haven't got the pipelines
quite the way they want,
it's taken them months to kind of remediate these sort of
issues, so they're still at risk for quite a long period of time.
We turned around in 48 hours,
globally. Which is amazing,
right, when you think about it.
So when you're, when you're talking to,
uh, when you're talking, if you think about
why we came here today.
What we wanted to do today is give you some insights
into AWS
about how we build things, why we build
them the way we do,
how we do deployment,
the, the care we take to think about
uh the various risks that we're under,
you know, whether it's the API calls, whether it's the pizza.
I don't know which pizza shop this is, but the
pizza shop that you're talking about, he likes pizza,
who knew, right?
Um, we wanted to understand
how to think about this,
you know, so that you can explain it to people.
That's really important to us and
we're actually spending a lot of time in, uh,
in our own industry,
uh, with, uh, financial services, which is a highly
regulated industry.
And has to think about all these things
and we're spending a lot of time
helping everybody to kind of kind of come up with a common
model in their thinking, so you know
we're trying to evangelize this sort of thoughts. It it
seems pretty simple,
but it's a good framing for a lot of these things.
And you and the other thing is
there are always gonna be risks that we haven't even
thought about.
So the fact that we've thought about a lot of risks and we've kind of
built these capa capabilities,
you've got that two pizza team working
together
in the way that we discussed, and then you've got the the
bigger sort of uh
uh coming together in our
operational weekly meetings, right,
which really is a spin the wheel exercise.
It, it's,
I was quite shocked when I first saw it, but it's very
much no blame culture,
get to the bottom of things as Rob said.
This, this is why
uh when we get into this and we explain to
everybody why we think
about things in a risk framework and how we tick
them all off,
uh, then when it gets into kind of these
uh issues when we have
uh security issues, we're able to go and rectify
those very, very quickly.
Excellent. So,
Thank you very much for your time today.
Please, uh, make sure you fill out the session survey
in the mobile app.
One last call out for resilience
meetup
at the Caesar's Forum meetups today at
4 o'clock, I believe, or maybe 5 o'clock.
I think it's 4 o'clock.
Uh, come with your most difficult resilience
questions, anything that you wanna know about, uh, AWS
resilience, your own resilience service
events. And there's a team of experts on
hand to answer that. You head to the meetup
section at Caesar's Forum.
Thank you very much. Thank you so much for coming.
Good job, Rob.